[Music]
a mirror that shatters without warning
a trail of cracker crumbs strewn across
the floor
two tiny hand prints that appear on a
cake
everyone at 124 bluestone road knows
their house is haunted
but there's no mystery about the spirit
tormenting them
this ghost is the product of an
unspeakable trauma the legacy of a
barbaric history
that hangs over much more than this lone
homestead
so begins beloved tony morrison's
pulitzer
prize-winning novel about the suffering
wrought by slavery
and the wounds that persist in its wake
published in 1987
beloved tells the story of sethe a woman
who escaped enslavement
when the novel opens setha has been
living free for over a decade
her family has largely dissolved seth's
mother-in-law died years earlier
and her two sons ran away from fear of
the specter
seth's daughter denver remains in the
house but the pair live a half-life
shunned by the wider community the two
have only each other
and the ghost for company seth is
consumed by thoughts of the spirit
whom she believes to be her eldest
daughter
when a visitor from seth's old life
returns and threatens the ghost away
it seems like the start of a new
beginning for her family
but what comes in the ghost's place may
be even harder to bear
as with much of morrison's work beloved
investigates the roles of trauma
and love in african american history
morrison writes about black identities
in a variety of contexts
but her characters are united by their
desire to find love
and be loved even when it's painful some
of her novels explore
when love challenges social conventions
like the forbidden affection that grows
between the townsfolk of paradise
and their fugitive neighbors other works
examine how we can be blind to the love
we already possess
in sula one character realizes that it's
not her marriage
but rather one of her friendships that
embodies the great love of her life
perhaps morrison's most famous
exploration of the difficulty of love
takes place in beloved here the author
considers how the human spirit is
diminished
when you know the things and people you
love most will be taken away
morrison shows that slavery is
destructive to love in all forms
poisoning both enslaved people and their
enslavers
beloved examines the dehumanizing
effects of the slave trade in numerous
ways
some are straightforward such as
referring to enslaved people
as animals with monetary value but
others are more subtle
setha and paul d the visitor from her
old plantation
are described as trying to live an
unlivable life
their coping mechanisms are different
sether remains mired in her past
while paul d disassociates himself
completely
but in both cases it's clear each
character
has been irreparably scarred
morrison also blends perspectives and
timelines to convey how the trauma of
slavery
ripples across various characters and
time periods
as she delves into the psyche of
townspeople enslavers
and previously enslaved people she
exposes conflicting viewpoints on
reality
this tension shows the limitations of
our own perspectives
and the ways in which some characters
are actively avoiding the reality of
their actions
but in other instances the characters
shifting memories
align perfectly capturing the collective
trauma that haunts the story
though beloved touches on dark subjects
the book is also filled with beautiful
prose
highlighting its character's capacity
for love and vulnerability
in a stream of consciousness sequence
written from seth's perspective
morrison unspools memories of
subjugation alongside moments of
tenderness
like a baby reaching for a mother's
earrings spring colors
and freshly painted stairs seth's
mother-in-law had been painted white
she recalls so you could see your way to
the top
where lamplight didn't reach
throughout the book morrison asks us to
consider hope
in the dark and to question what freedom
really means
she urges readers to ponder the power we
have over each other
and to use that power wisely in this way
beloved remains a testimony to the
destructiveness of hate
the redeeming power of love and the
responsibility we bear
to heed the voices of the past
toni morrison once said if there's a
book that you want to read
but it hasn't been written yet then you
must write it
unimpressed with the sci-fi she read as
a kid writer octavia butler did just
that
explore her stunningly inventive works
with this video